that's mr harris he was the neighborhood
butcher but on halloween he became sweet
tooth the candy pimple
halloween candy so what you guys got in
the bags give it up to sweet dude
why don't you leave us alone
no this is a little light
but i'm gonna give you kids a chance to
make it right for old sweet dude give my
sister her candy back now i was so glad
drew didn't have a sword do i hear that
no
i thought
my new kids get the chicken and the
treat
and you best to have all my candy
[Music]
sweet tooth died two years later of a
bad case of gingivitis
mama's some pimp took all our candy what
if i had my sword it wouldn't have
happened oh i'm sorry you know what next
time i'm sending y'all over to park
slope park slope was the last thing on
my mind for the first time in my life i
was going to a party oh and chris i got
your costume
[Music]
do that thing do that thing
[Music]
one more time
you left the address in the telephone
number right
i'm gonna leave it on the table okay
don't mess up my coat
even though i didn't know the phone
number i was just going to the party a
few blocks away as long as i came back
on time i didn't have anything to worry
about
[Music]
now this is what i'm talking about i
waited 13 years to get to my first party
and now i'm here let's get this party
started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they act like they've never seen a kid
in a print suit before
i sure hope that's a girl and a
[Music]
guy planned parenthood here we come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jerome's liver died three years before
he did
[Music]
jerome was right at that moment i
realized a woman needs a man to take
control of a situation and that's what i
intended to do
you wanna dance
hell no are you crazy
actually all she said was no but when
you're 13 no sounds a lot like this why
are you dressed in that stupid costume
what are you supposed to be anyways
why are you here didn't nobody invite
you i invited drew
get out of my face
[Music]
hey you all right
i'm gonna be okay
you wanna dance
this is a slow song
i know
you better
[Music]
lisa patterson was the first girl that
ever had pity on me
to this day i love pity
all right that's it
man i should have felt her ass
brother's gotta try
maybe next time
[Music]
[Music]
you